it was much easier to go without heroin
in Finland than be in Baltimore letting
men blow me for 10 bucks for sure so you
know what I mean it's like H I'll just
endure it because I'll get paid out of
it and I'll just make it happen on the
next go around there's no justice in
that we we we weighed nothing we started
off I was expecting I was going to get
some like that Bo nothing [__]
crickets to my guy yeah that was not
there's no justice weight there but
that's my you know justification of so
so that was a go-to money maker in
Baltimore letting guys blow you yeah but
what about what about guys that wanted
you to blow them and it never happened
it never oh we lost eye contact when you
said
that scale of
Justice F you
R oh [__] Tony Rob J
over here I got to believe that in that
situation it's like all right well if if
a guy blowing you is 10 bucks you know
maybe like if I'm going to yeah if
you're going to be the blower then
that's got to you know every
everything's got a price why do heroin
addicts always like itch their nose is
that a thing like they always like I
used to itch everything it wasn't just
my nose that's that opiates are called
itchy and scratchies yeah really yep mhm
and I was never really into it it was
annoying to me to be itching I would
take these morphine pills and and I was
just like man I don't when would you
take these morphine pills you didn't get
addicted like that's pretty rare I mean
I would uh I would take morphine pills
one of when I was giving them I I I
loved it I loved it that was just he
would get annoyed with having to itch
for more of theme pills but I I can
recall vividly being locked in a hotel
with him and and like him not like
really letting us leave the the room
until we watched footage of him and
being terrified of him seeing us out of
eyesight that annoyed itching annoyed
him God forbid he
itches Jesus Christ and I'm the bad guy
here yeah yeah you've always been like
that huh yeah imagine imagine how bad it
was before dude I remember being okay
soak us through uh some some prison
pocket stuff like where we're
particularly fascinated because you you
might be aware about Vinnie's experience
with the prison P I am I am did you see
his his reenactment on
it I did God bless you man yeah that was
that was a rough one that that
reenactment was it was a lot bigger of a
package than when I went into jail yeah
a criminally underviewed video on my
YouTube channel shocking demonstration
of how to smuggle things into prison
yeah the times are changing maybe boys
I don't know maybe it's suppressed yeah
maybe people like I don't know so here's
how so I negotiate 11 and a half to 23
30 weekends 6 months house arrest right
um while we're doing that I'm still
getting high the [__] the suitcase
AKA my [__] is in full effect every
Friday I load it up with drugs get in
sniff them sleep my weekend away
discharge Sunday night Monday night
religiously we have that radio show on
serious satellite yeah radio bam I
forget you know it was a room maybe two
times the size of this and it's just
like this and there's a guy working the
boards and I forget that we're going
live to the nation the majority of the
time and we'd be drinking drugging
whatever and you just forget you feel
like you're talking to your buddies and
uh I I proceeded on one of these
episodes to talk about how the um the
cosos the white shirs of of George W
Hill the the the facility I was
incarcerating at the time um were
worthless and how my dead grandmother
could do a better job than them and how
I was uh in particular sneaking my drugs
in on the weekend wow so that was a
Monday night I then go back on a Friday
and and they say Mr Novak get over here
when they're doing roll call for the
intake and I'm like what so they pull me
out of this line they put me in the
other line they then put me in uh the
intake Wing uh of just the regular
population of the jail and and I'm in
the cell and I do my drugs and Saturday
I'm just thinking it's a mixup maybe I
don't know what's wrong but there's a
bang on the door and there's one of
those white shirts I was talking about
and he said come with us and they take
me into this control room where there's
a whole bunch of white shirts white
shirts all sergeant in there they're
standing in a circle and they put me
like in the middle and and there's a one
who's sitting like in the corner on a
computer and he will not look at me and
he could tell he's the boss and he
starts repeating ver batim what I said
on that radio show as the other ones
just start smacking me around oh
smacking around did they uh did they
investigate your pocket did they uh no
no they what they did was they uh so you
had a fully loaded butthole I had
already did it at that point cuz I had
made it in but they revoked my situation
right there basically and made my next
year a living hell and that jail
actually was uh raid at one of the most
corrupt jails um because it was
privately owned at the time it's now
publicly owned
so there there was no more storage no no
that there was no more release dates for
me I I and what they would do is they
would move me to these different blocks
first they put me um in in the shoe
special housing unit where it's 23 23 in
one I'm lacking to sell 23 hours a day I
can come out one hour a day one day uh
three days a week um to get a shower and
they unlock you and you could only have
a a Bible if you had one no reading
materials no commentary and this is
right in the beginning so I'm I'm
detoxing from Methadone Xanax and heroin
at the same time and I'm hallucinating
I'm thinking that the the warden is
sleeping with my ex- fiance I'm I'm
thinking that I'm on the prices right um
I'm feeding this imaginary pig that I
named minson and minson yeah and I have
this Sy and his name streets he's this
uh Muslim Jihad guy great guy and he
like caught me jerking off one day on
the top cell he's like yo you jerking
off I'm like yeah like I feel some kind
of [__] way about that not like any
particular way but just some kind of way
like it's a little V give me a little
Direction here you mad or you happy
where are we going with this Jesus and
then so they put me from there to
another block and then once they
realized they couldn't do anything more
with me they revoked my time they would
then come come and they'd rip all the
cell blocks apart just to make the other
prisoners mad at me because any block
they put me on meant that I was hot and
they were going to disrupt the block you
know H do you like shopping on Amazon I
do and good news is sto's butt wipes for
your butthole are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get sto's hot sauce for your
butthole plus sto's butthole destroyer
and steo butt wipes for your butthole
it's the butthole bundle available on
Amazon right
now yeah dude